today on the Matt Walsh show police in
North Carolina broke up a peaceful
protest and arrested protesters who had
gone to the State Capitol to speak out
against the governor's shut down orders
and the police department explained that
they were breaking up the protests and
arresting people because protesting is
quote not essential I very much disagree
with that and I think there's a
discussion we need to have about this
this word essential and what does it
mean exactly and who has the authority
really to decide what's essential and
what isn't so we're going to talk about
all that coming up also five headlines
including Attorney General bar speaking
of our essential rights is siding with
churchgoers in Mississippi who were
fined for attending a church service on
Easter and at the end of show I want to
tell you about the most incredible email
I think I've ever received from a reader
and this is well it's a story you're
gonna want to hear so stick around for
that all that coming up but to start
with
like I said a group of peaceful
protesters gathered in Raleigh North
Carolina on Tuesday to call for the
reopening of the state they stood
outside they observed the guidelines of
social distancing they were you know
more than six feet apart more
importantly though they observe the
guidelines of the First Amendment which
plain as day protects quote the right of
the people peaceably to assemble and to
petition the government for redress of
grievances as the First Amendment says
they were assembled they were peaceful
and they were petitioning their
government for a specific and reasonable
thing namely the right to go back to
work and feed their families that is
their grievance I think a very
justifiable grievance and they were
petitioning the government so it seems
like they had all of the First Amendment
bases covered right but they seem to
have forgotten as many of us I guess
have forgotten that our founding fathers
apparently when when codifying our
inherent human rights into the legal
document known as the Bill of Rights
included the important caveat that all
of this stuff evaporates and is a moot
point if there is a virus and people are
getting sick so it's all you know you
have a right to peaceful assembly a
right to speech and religion and
everything else unless people are
getting sick in which case this is this
is all this is all meaningless now it's
it's it's easy to forget that it's in
there but
because it was apparently written in
invisible ink and you can only read it
if you have a special decoder lens that
you're looking through and actually I'm
not sure if that's true or not that at
least appears to be the legal theory of
the governor of North Carolina and his
law enforcement agents as Raleigh police
descended upon this peaceful assembly
and instructed it to disperse at least
one of the protesters was arrested now
when asked to justify their actions the
Raleigh Police Department explained on
Twitter that and this is a direct quote
they said protesting is a non-essential
activity and in case you think that
maybe this is just some intern or you
know who knows whoever is the person who
updates the Raleigh Police Department
Twitter I don't know who that is and you
might think well that's just that person
going rogue and making this statement
lest you think that the Raleigh Police
Department issued a statement in
response to the backlash over all of
this and they double down on this the
First Amendment is not essential thing
this is what they said the goal of the
Raleigh Police Department is to help
residents remain as safe as possible
during the Cova 19 pandemic by reminding
them to observe the Wake County State
home Proclamation and the governor's
executive orders in these unprecedented
times and unusual circumstances both the
governor and the county have declared a
state of emergency under these current
and temporary declarations protesting is
not listed as an essential function well
there you have it the Bill of Rights the
governor did not list the Bill of Rights
as essential and so therefore it is not
because the governor decides now I quite
expect the bootlickers out there who
have already supported the government's
right to arrest people for going to
church I expect those you know that camp
the bootlicking camp will find this
reasoning totally acceptable but good
Americans who value freedom and am I
saying that you're a bad American if you
support the government's right to arrest
people for peace of peaceably protesting
yeah I am I'm saying you're a very bad
American in fact and I'm ashamed to call
you a countryman
I really am if you would if you would
support this I'm not saying you're a bad
American if you support quarantines and
shutdowns in general but if you're gonna
side with the government arresting
people for four clearly exercising their
First Amendment rights then you're a bad
American those tho Americans who value
freedom will recognize all of this as
the Orwellian insanity that it is if a
politician can unilaterally abolish our
fundamental liberties simply by
declaring them non-essential then we
have no fundamental liberties the whole
idea becomes a farce or at best it's a
sort of symbolic concept that we sing
about and we write poems about and that
makes us feel good inside but really it
has no practical applications it doesn't
matter this is the point all this all
this stuff about essential this word
essentials being bandied about quite a
bit it doesn't matter if a particular
protest or church service is essential
that's a matter of opinion anyway and
the opinion of a politician or a
bureaucrat or the governor should have
no more weight on a matter like this
than anybody else's opinion because
they're not supposed to be governing
based on their opinion we are not
supposed to be under the rule of our
governors opinion but that that's not
the point when it comes to essential the
point is that the right to protest just
like the right to practice our religion
is essential the government has claimed
absolute authority to decree what is
essential and what is not but but when
it to claims this Authority for itself
we have to remember that the word
essential has two definitions that are
related but not exactly the same so the
first definition is something is
essential if it's necessary or it's
indispensable or you know if it's like a
physical necessity okay so that's the we
might say drinking water is essential
and yes it's true that in that sense get
going to a protest or go
Church is not like drinking water it's
not because you could you could not do
those things and you're not going to die
but then there's the second definition
and under that definition it essential
means pertaining to or constituting the
essence of a thing
in other words inherent something is
essential if it's inherent and in that
sense in the deeper sense of essential
there is no doubt that our right to
protest and our right to practice our
religion publicly is essential in that
it is inherent to our nature as human
beings it is in our essence as human
beings essential governments across the
country have used the fact that these
rights are not physical necessities as
an excuse to deny the essentialness of
these rights to our basic human nature
they are based they are denying the
doctrine upon which our country was
founded and and that should really
concern us that the governor can
overturn that in one fell swoop
just by issuing an executive order the
whole point the whole point of our
country the reason it exists in the
first place is that you cannot overturn
those rights they are always there and
they're always essential
now we're there's there's another
important point about North Carolina
specifically in the situation that it's
in and we'll talk about that in just a
second but first I want to give a thank
you to this sponsor and all of our
sponsors who are supporting the show
during this very difficult time it's
difficult for everybody and I want to
say it's all the listeners and thank you
as well for supporting the show and
supporting the Daily wire in general and
keep keep it keeping us going and if you
you know it just I appreciate everyone
who listens to these little ads we do
and if you have have the money and you
hear something about about a product
that you really like and you think that
you could use I would you know ask and
encourage you to to support that sponsor
and thank everyone who does all right I
want to tell you about our friends over
at paint your life you know having
artwork in the house that's I know when
I was a
living on my own for five or six years
one of the ways you can tell is a
bachelor pad is there's no art of any
kind on the walls it's just there's
random like stains and smudges and
things on the walls but there was no no
no artwork or anything but when you want
to have a nice home especially with a
family and everything you want to have
some hard work and that's that's and you
want the artwork to be meaningful to you
to be beautiful and meaning meaningful
and that's why you need paint your life
if you're looking for a way to feel
connected to your loved ones especially
when you can't be near them like we keep
like we like we can't be right now
you've got to try paint your life calm
you can get a professional hand painted
portrait created from any photo at a
truly affordable price and this is not
like some Photoshop thing this is you're
sending in the photo of course digitally
and and they're gonna have real artists
good artists actually paint this thing
and I'll tell you one thing I like about
it is it's a very hands-on process so
through the entire process of the of
them painting it they're gonna you know
keep you updated and if there's any
questions if you have anything you want
to customize or change they're going to
do that for you very responsive and I
just cannot recommend it enough right
now as a limited time offer you get 30%
off your painting
that's right 30% off of an already
affordable price plus you get free
shipping so to get this special offer
text the word matte to 64,000 that's
matte m82 64,000 all right one other
point about North Carolina is they're as
they're you know trying to overturn the
First Amendment North Carolina has 5000
confirmed cases of coronavirus and a
little over 400 hospitalizations that's
in a state of 10 million people spread
out over a hundred counties so it's it's
in its coronavirus death toll is as of
yesterday was a hundred and eight so
you're talking about an average of
slightly more than one death per county
now those numbers equal a sad situation
and a serious situation but they do not
equal a cataclysmic emergency North
Carolina like most of the states in the
Union has never had a coronavirus
emergency and even if
an emergency could justify the
suspension of our fundamental human
rights which it can't in my view but
even if it could this for North Carolina
would not be such an emergency so what
the governor is doing is exploiting the
virus and the fear that it generates to
seize unprecedented power and this is
what we're seeing across the country and
we absolutely should not stand for it
all right let's go on to headlines
number one
as mentioned before headline from the
hill says Attorney General Barr says
government may not impose special
restrictions on religious gatherings
reading now from the article it says
Attorney General William bar said
Tuesday that the government quote may
not impose special restrictions on
religious gatherings as churches across
the country raise eyebrows with large
in-person ceremonies conducted against
the advice of health officials a little
bit of a you can tell the writer of this
article you can tell how they felt about
it bar emphasized recommendations from
federal health officials that people
practice social distancing and avoid
large geyser gatherings noting that the
Constitution does allow some temporary
restrictions on our liberties that would
not be tolerated in normal circumstances
but even in times of emergency when
reasonable and temporary restrictions
are placed on the right on our rights
the First Amendment and federal
statutory law prohibit discrimination
against religious institutions and
religious believers
thus government may not impose special
restrictions on religious activity that
do not also apply to similar non
religious activity and then he filed a
memo in support of the congregants who
were fined in Mississippi $500 for
attending a drive-in service so I'm look
I'm glad for this letter from Barr I'm
especially glad that he came out in
defense of the church in Mississippi but
the problem with this caveat of may not
impose special restrictions that don't
also apply to other places is that it
clearly gives the government and out all
they have to do is claim that they're
restricting Church is the same way
they're restricting other quote
non-essential places and that's why the
real issue again the real thing that we
have to talk about and that has to be
addressed is the government's authority
to declare something non-essential in
the first place
because that's what this comes down to
number two Barack Obama has finally come
out after all this time to endorse his
quote good friend Joe Biden I'm so proud
to endorse Joe Biden for President of
the United States
choosing Joe to be my vice president was
one of the best decisions I ever made
and it became a close friend and I
believe Joe has all the qualities we
need in a president right now he's
someone whose own life has taught him
how to persevere how to bounce back when
you've been knocked down when Joe talks
with parents who've lost their jobs we
hear the son of a man who once knew the
pain of having to tell his children that
he'd lost his I know he'll surround
himself with good people experts
scientists military officials who
actually know how to run the government
and care about doing a good job running
the government and know how to work with
our allies and who will always put the
American people's interests above their
own
very interesting so Biden has knowledge
experience empathy grace he's a great
leader close friend Obama is one of his
the best things he's ever done in his
life is appoint Joe Biden vice president
all of that but you didn't endorse him
until he was the only option left on the
table so that's that that's these the
best best guy I mean you couldn't ask
for a better guy great leader everything
but but yeah I had to wait until he was
the only he's also the only option I
have right now so that's like if the if
the team captain picks you last in gym
class and then tells you later that he
selected you for your great athleticism
and in skill you know it just doesn't
it's not very convincing number three
headline on NPR comm says New York
City's Cova 19 death toll soars past
10,000 you know sounds that sounds bad
and it is but then you have to actually
read the article and then you see this
New York City has drastically increased
its estimate of the number of people
killed by Cova 19 to include probable
victims who were not tested the new
number is ten thousand three hundred six
it continues for weeks firefighters and
paramedics have been recording a massive
spike in deaths at home around New York
City the deceased were presumed to be
victims of the krona virus but we're
never tested now city officials have
recalculated the toll that the virus has
taken and reached a staggering number
adding nearly four thousand to the total
so what they're telling us is that they
reached this this staggering toll
because they're adding in people who did
not test positive for coronavirus
they're just assuming that these people
died of chrono virus okay but but we're
still told you know you can't claim that
there that they are artificially
inflating the death toll if you claim
that you're a horrible person your
conspiracy monger right even though
they're telling us pretty much that's
exactly what they're doing and on the
basis that you know they say paramedics
have recorded a massive spike in deaths
at home around New York City okay I
don't deny that that there obviously is
a corona virus outbreak in New York City
and it's really bad okay yeah I don't
you don't need to inflate the death toll
it's it in reality is a very bad
situation and there obviously are going
to be people who die at home from this
virus tragically but if you think about
why is there a massive spike of people
dying at home what could be another
contributing factor well maybe it's that
people are locked in their homes okay so
when you lock people in their homes all
day for weeks on end you're gonna have
more people dying at home whereas a
normal circumstance maybe they would
have died somewhere else okay so that so
that that also has to have something to
do with it and you're gonna have people
who would have died anyway
and died for reasons that have nothing
to do with coronavirus died at home and
if you show up and just assume they died
of coronavirus then you're gonna end up
with an artificially inflated death toll
number for a headline in the Daily wire
US officials raised alarm about wuhan
lab researching bat coronaviruses in
2018 military investigating this is
pretty incredible so let's
this says a bombshell report from
Washington Post on Tuesday revealed that
US officials sounded the alarm about the
Wuhan Institute of Eire ology back in
2018 over safety concerns as the lab
research coronavirus from bats The
Washington Post says in January 2018 the
US Embassy in Beijing took the unusual
step of repeatedly sending us science
diplomats to the Wuhan institute of
neurology which had in 2015 become
China's first laboratory to achieve the
highest level of international bio
research safety what the US officials
learned during their visits concern them
so much they dispatched two diplomatic
cables categorizing categorized that's
sensitive but unclassified back to
Washington and I mean go to Washington
Post and read the entire report the
point is you know there's there's very
real concern here obviously and you know
I think about there were a lot of people
myself included I certainly wasn't the
only person a lot of just normal common
sense people who weeks ago were saying
it's probably not a coincidence that
you've got this global pandemic that
started in a place we're sitting right
there at the center of it is this is
this virus lab you know probably not a
coincidence there are coincidences in
life but but you know it's it's when
something seems like it's probably not a
coincidence most the time it's not and
those of us who weeks ago we're pointing
this out and saying hey you know what
about that virus lab does that maybe
have something to do with this weeks ago
we were told by the experts and the
media that we're a bunch of conspiracy
theorists and we're stupid and they
scolded us and now we're being told that
oh yeah you know what actually yeah it
might be that so there's been a lot of
that happening in fact also with masks
you think back a month ago there were
people just common sense normal people
buying masks and and and saying maybe we
should wear masks and again we were
scolded by the experts including the
including the Surgeon General saina you
know what it does masks isn't gonna do
anything for you you [ __ ] stop wearing
masks
fast forward a month and now they're
saying oh yeah you know what about those
masks maybe you were right about that
turns out that common sense once again
prevails before we move on to the last
headline I want to tell you about our
friends over at Duke canon maybe you've
had this experience as a man looking for
body washes and so many of the body
washes that you find at the store are
very disappointing they're just sort of
thin and watery flowery feminine you
know just it's it's not what you need as
a man when it comes to you need a manly
body wash luckily enough there's a new
product from Duke Canon supply company
called thick thick is three times
thicker than common body washes it's the
high viscosity I don't even know what
high viscosity means but it sounds good
it's the high viscosity alternative to
watching your money run down the shower
drain thick comes in a big old container
you crack it open like a like a like a
can of beer like you crack open a can of
beer in the shower I know I have a beer
in the shower every morning it's how
it's how I get things going in the
morning
Duke canon thick high viscosity body
wash comes in four distinctly masculine
sense there is the scent of
accomplishment the scent of naval
supremacy we all know that scent when we
smell it old glory and productivity
nothing like the smell of productivity
especially with all these shutdowns
happening there's not a lot of
productivity so you'll eat if you can't
be productive you at least want to smell
productive thick is made with
plant-based thickeners for superior
lather so you're not going to need that
that whatever that puffy thing is in the
shower the loofah anymore you're not
gonna need that visit Duke Kannan calm
and use the promo code walls for 15% off
your entire order free shipping with
orders over $35 a range of new canon
men's premium products are also
available available at your local target
all right finally there's an article in
538 making the rounds today it attempts
to explain and justify why the world
shut down for coronavirus but and this
is a question against speaking of
common-sense things a lot of
common-sense people have been asking we
shut down for coronavirus we didn't shut
down for Ebola SARS swine flu there's
been a lot of there have been many
different outbreaks that have happened
in modern
times recently and we didn't shut down
for those now this article in 538
written by Kelly Rogers tries to explain
that and basically to summarize her
argument she says that the other
diseases were either not as contagious
like Ebola which is extremely deadly but
but but harder to contract or not as
deadly like the swine flu and that's why
she argues the shutdown's makes sense
for coronavirus but they wouldn't have
made sense for these other things but I
want to go to the because there's a
problem with the logic here I think I
want to go to the section on the swine
flu in this article and here's what she
writes in the spring of 2009 a new
version of the h1n1 influenza virus the
virus that caused the 1918 Spanish flu
pandemic emerged and began to spread
rapidly the swine flu was killed
anywhere from 150 one thousand people to
five hundred and seventy five thousand
people worldwide since 2009 according to
the CDC and may have infected over a
billion people the swine flu spreads
easily person to person just like Cova
19 and possibly even from people who
were pre-symptomatic goes on and says so
why didn't the swine flu overwhelm our
healthcare systems the main difference
is that it ended up being a much milder
and less deadly infection there are a
range of estimates estimated case
fatality rates for swine flu but even
the highest less than 0.1% is much lower
than the current estimates for Kovan 19
and then it quotes
ouchy who says that the fatality rate
was quite low and that's why it didn't
get the same kind of response all right
but up to half a million people dying
from a virus is still a lot isn't it
you're talking about half a million
people and here's the problem
most of the rhetoric that's used to
justify the shutdowns centers around the
value of human life and how we have to
make sacrifices to save people and and
you know we can't we can't sacrifice the
elderly and people with pre-existing
conditions and so on and people are more
important than money and all this kind
of stuff
which of course I agree with all of that
you can agree with all that that life is
is is is inherently valuable and people
are more important than money you know
we shouldn't be sacrified no we you can
agree with that and still think that the
shut downs are the wrong move but that's
the argument for the most part we've all
heard this stuff a million times and not
just on Facebook and in Twitter comments
but from the actual government officials
who are instituting these policies
they're the ones who are offering this
as a reason but we got to save human
life human life is valuable so on and so
on and so forth all of that all of it
would clearly apply to the five thousand
four rather five hundred thousand people
who died from a swine flu so you could
say all you want that fewer people will
die from this or fewer people will die
from the swine flu then it then will die
from the corona virus and you may be
right about that but that has nothing
really to do with the justification that
we're being given for these shutdowns we
are told point blank it's about
preserving human life and if that's what
it's about then you have to explain why
you know yes five hundred thousand
people maybe fewer people then will
ultimately die from chrono virus or
could have died or whatever I don't know
if that's true or not but I'll grant it
for the sake of argument yet that's
still five hundred thousand people and
so if we're doing shutdowns to save
lives why not those people and if you're
saying that five hundred thousand people
is not enough if that's that not enough
of a death toll to justify a shutdown
where is your line and you have to be
able to explain that now let's go to
your daily cancellation but before we do
that I want to give you a word from our
good friends over at the Daily wire The
Daily wire I want to tell you about this
deal and if you haven't heard about this
deal you need to hear about it when you
become a daily wire and insider plus or
all-access member
right now this isn't how it usually
usually you become a member you get the
you get the leftist tears tumblr right
you get one tumblr with if you become a
member right now you get not one but two
of our highly coveted leftist tears
tumblers and I mean if if you know look
I got one tumbler and it changed my life
completely forever I was never the same
again and that's and this is what you
hear from everybody who gets this tumblr
they all talk about the way that it
changed their life and made their life
worth living in a way that it wasn't
before I know I wake up every morning
especially in these times and sometimes
are very depressed and I think what's
the point of going on and I look at my
left is tears tumblr and I realize
that's why I'm going on for that tumblr
okay this is not an exaggeration this
I've heard this not just from heard this
from many people if if one tumblr can
give your life meaning in this way
imagine what two tumblers can do that's
all I'm saying so become a daily wire
insider plus or all-access member and
you get ten percent off with coupon code
Walsh plus you get the you get that you
get the two tumblers as well so you want
to make sure you go ahead and do that
alright today we're gonna cancel all the
media outlets all of them who have been
publishing headlines like this from Al
Jazeera headline is dozens buried in New
York mass grave as coronavirus deaths
surged so dozens buried in a mass grave
in New York then it continues New York
as burying some of its dead in a mass
grave as its daily coronavirus death
toll reaches grim new records and every
major outlet that I've seen has reported
on these mass graves and they do it with
the kind of sensational rhetoric that
you know and tone that you might expect
and that on the surface seems justified
I mean they're using mass graves now
that's how bad it's gotten the problem
though is that these mass graves are not
new New York has been burying people in
this mass grave since the 19th century
in fact they think over a million bodies
have been buried there over the last
century plus and and not all from the
coronavirus of course now it's true that
they're putting more people than usual
in these mass graves we don't know how
many of them are from the current of
was epidemic but probably a certain
portion of them heart you know stands to
reason but that means the real headline
should read like this more people than
usual being buried in New York's
century-old mass gravesite some of them
might have died from the coronavirus
that's what the real headline is it
would be an accurate headline but it
doesn't have the same kind of
sensationalist flair to it so instead
they just report that people are being
buried in mass graves and I think the
reason I want to point to this is um
first of all just to clarify if you've
seen these headlines I know a lot of
people I've seen these these stories
being passed around online and it's it's
very startling of course but just to
just to give you the perspective on it
also I think it's a good lesson in how
the media manipulates and it shows why I
don't really like the term fake news you
know and I don't use it that often
because the term fake news I think
misses the point is it fake news that
people are being buried in mass graves
in New York no not at all it's not fake
news people are being buried in mass
graves is it fake news that some of the
dead are probably coronavirus fatalities
no probably not so the the fake news
quote-unquote comes from the emphasis
and the lack of context and the
sensationalist framing on it and it
comes in the the facts they decide not
to report or not to emphasize or not to
put in the headline versus the facts
that they do put in the headline that's
where it comes from and it still gives
the media this plausible deniability you
can always deny the fake news charge on
the basis that what it's reporting is
technically true yet it is misleading
the public and it's intentionally
misleading and and and they know that's
what they're doing but they're not
misleading the public by literally
making up fake stories out of whole
cloth the way people talk about fake
news from the media it's like they it's
it's like it's like people think the
media just invent stories like you've
got a reporter sitting in his house may
the story as if he's writing a fiction
story and that might happen sometimes
but vast majority of the time that's not
what they're doing and it's important
for us to realize this so that we can
detect that quote-unquote fake news and
was it now usually what they're
reporting is is probably basically true
but what we have to look at is what are
they emphasizing how are they framing it
what details are they leaving out and
what stories are they ignoring because I
think that's where the bias comes in all
right finally something a little
different today usually this is where I
would read some emails from listeners
but today instead of reading an email I
want to talk about an email that I
received and I'm not going to read it
because it has a lot of personal
information that I don't feel
comfortable reading but I do have
permission at least to talk about the
email so and that's good because it's
it's honestly the most incredible email
I've ever gotten from a reader and
that's not an exaggeration so for
context we have to go back five years
five years ago I wrote an article I was
writing for the blaze at the time and
the article that I wrote addressed it
was addressed to and directed to a woman
who had posted a goodbye letter to the
child that she was going to abort the
following day and from what I remember
she posted it on Reddit I think and I
still I still remember this seeing this
and it was very disturbing you know this
woman wrote this letter to her child she
was gonna kill saying calling a child
the little one and saying how much she
loves a child and explaining why she has
to go through with the abortion and I
wrote my article to her pleading with
her not to destroy her child and because
I figured that by posting this online as
she had done she must have been at least
partially at some level hoping that
someone would talk her out of it because
that's the only reason why you would
post something like that if you're very
confident in what you're gonna do you're
not going to write this bizarre open
letter to your childhood of course is
never going to read it and post it
online
so I figured she was looking for someone
who talked her out of it and so I tried
to do that I have no idea if I succeeded
and I never heard from the woman
chances are she probably never even saw
what I wrote and I knew that when I
wrote it
not many people did see what I wrote The
Post sort of faded into oblivion after
getting just a few clicks which was fine
of course because I didn't write it for
clicks and and I did write it
specifically to one person who I knew
would probably not see it and so you
know but it was worth a shot anyway
fast forward five years two nights ago I
got an email actually it was a message
on Twitter a direct message from a woman
a different woman who had quite a
powerful story to tell I thought and I
can only sum it up but she told me that
she read my article when I posted it
five years ago and she had been wanting
to write to me if these past five years
to tell me about this and finally she
decided to she read the article after
she had just gone to Planned Parenthood
and taken an abortion pill so she had
made the decision to abort her child and
had begun the process of going through
with it and I think what the abortion
pills usually multiple doses you have to
take so she had taken one dose at least
after making that decision she was at
home that night and she was on the
Internet and she said that she was kind
of scrolling through the internet
looking for something she didn't know
exactly what she was looking for but she
was just scrolling and and was
distraught she saw my article she read
it she was feeling profound regret and
sadness and guilt and a million emotions
that I can't even fathom yet she read
the whole thing multiple times she said
and she began to really mourn the loss
of her child
I mean deeply mourn again in a way that
just going through something emotionally
that I that I personally cannot even
fathom and then she saw an ad pop up for
abortion pill reversal long story short
her daughter turns five this year my
point in telling you this first of all
is it's just an incredible story I think
and also I want to acknowledge the
courage on this woman I mean
most people myself included you know we
can't bear to read things or listen to
perspectives that we simply disagree
with right if we have a differing
opinion we often don't have the
fortitude to hear someone out who
disagrees with us we don't even have the
courage to do that
so imagine the kind of courage it must
require if you can put yourself in this
woman's shoes after she'd already made
the choice to get the abortion and she
had gone through with it and she thought
that it was a done deal
it was irreversible and yet to listen to
the other perspective and to be willing
to confront her own decisions and think
critically about them and to be honest
with herself that's the other thing
we're all very good at doing is lying to
ourselves especially to justify the
things we've already done but she didn't
do that and I think that that just
requires courage unlike what most people
demonstrate in their lives which by the
way reversing an abortion pill that's my
other point bringing this up reversing
an abortion pill is possible it's by no
means a surefire bet it's and it's a
somewhat involved process mostly it
means taking as far as I am aware it
means taking progesterone multiple doses
she told me that she had to go on bed
rest for several days just hoping hoping
they would work and it did but you have
to really be committed to reversing it
and to saving her baby which she was so
and she now has three kids she's married
she has since married the father of her
children and they have a happy family
she sent me a family picture beautiful
kids beautiful family happy ending I
don't think for a minute that I played a
central role in all this I think it was
her love for her child and her courage
and her listening to God's calling on
her heart god I think moved her to go
online search for something she didn't
know what she found the article and then
most importantly she saw the ad and so
this is really a story about her and God
and her child so something positive to
end the show with for a change I know
that was very meaningful to me
and and you know it is also nice I guess
on a more on a personal note it's nice
that you know I've been doing this for a
long time putting a lot of content out
there and almost all of it is forgotten
ten seconds later including by myself so
to know that at least one thing made a
difference for one family is special to
me so there we go
there's my there's my happy sappy ending
I won't make a habit of it I promise so
we'll leave it there have a great day
everybody
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producer is our Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling our technical
producer is Austin Stephens edited by
Dany D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 a new study shows Americans
are worried but they're not worried
primarily about the coronavirus they're
worried about something that poses a far
more imminent risk to their lives and
livelihoods as the backlash against our
national lock downs begins to brew the
response from mayors and governors
separates the politician wheat from the
politician chaff then Joe Biden gets a
major endorsement now that there's no
other choice and the New York Times goes
into full damage control mode to cover
for grab happy Joe Biden all that more
check it out on the Michael Doyle show